now to David Simon's Daniel Wilk James
aqua Bella
Michael napkin and David M Kota we
present a scientific and engineering
award for the work of Adobe After
Effects alright gents come on up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you
Academy for honoring us and for honoring
After Effects After Effects is the fruit
of over 600 person years of labor so a
huge thank you to the approximately 100
team members who have worked on it over
the years and with whom we share this
award we wish we had time to mention you
all by name thank you to the folks who
contributed to the very first version in
1992 at a tiny startup the company of
science and heart especially David
Hartman who in addition to coding LED
feature decisions for the formative
first four years over many late nights
eating chicken babeon and thanks to
Sarah Allen and Russell Belfer for
contributing to the early design and
coding I want to give special
recognition to the talented dedicated
folks who have worked on After Effects
for over twenty years including Paul you
Sotelo for rock-solid quality
engineering with a perfect deadpan
digital Wizkid John Nelson for ram
preview and the puppet tool vladimir
Patoka for a no complaints attitude
toward color management Steve T Bors for
bringing quality engineering to the
third dimension punk-rocker James Landy
for cross-product quality engineering
and white box quality engineer Keiko
Yamada from whom no bug can hide for
long and thanks to everyone on the team
today who are continuing to innovate for
After Effects artists it's those artists
who inspire us with their beautiful work
and guide under our development through
guided development through spirited
feedback special thanks to the early
beta testers like Chris and Trish Mayer
who believed in us even when it was far
from clear that they should have more
personally I'd like to thank my wife
Becca and daughters Raina and Harriet
who made it all possible and worthwhile
and I'll finish by thanking my mother
who was still sharp at 81
soon after I told her about this award I
turned off the motion interpolation
setting on her TV so she could
so she could enjoy her favorite movies
in response she said I guess you really
do deserve that Nobel Prize
thanks mom
[Applause]
thank you well first of all I want to
thank Dave Simons because none of this
would have ever happened without him his
vision over an incredible period of time
made after-effects possible and I'd also
like to thank my father Jerry natka and
my mom Lois
my stepmom you did my wife Serena and my
daughter Zoey Olivia they believed in me
every step of the way and also I'd like
to thank professor Andes Van Damme from
Brown University because he took a
chance on me when I was a very
raggedy-looking freshman and gave me my
first intro to computer graphics that
made all this possible thank you I'll be
quick because I know how these things go
I just like to think my family mom and
dad and also Dave s and Dave age for
taking a chance on me or in the early
days oh hi there and also my friends Jon
Nelson and Polly Sotelo for being
friends and being there the whole time
all right thanks guys
I want to thank my beautiful wife Karen
for putting up with me working so much
and I want to thank my mom for believing
in me and I want to thank Dave Simon's
my personal angel for mentoring me
through through the very beginning years
and thank you so much I really humbled
and honored by this award thank you
hello I'd like to thank my lovely wife
and beautiful wife from you up my two
children my mom and dad and my band
members who you know probably watching
this on YouTube dust mop and Dave
Simon's of course for taking a chance on
me thank you all
Thanks
[Applause]